did the 1994 crime bill that's the super
predator bill
so he did the super predator bill and
when you look at it but mark levin is
right he's a hundred percent president
no matter what you let me
make any difference and i have to say
i've said it many times and let me be
clear again i condemn the kkk
i condemn all white supremacists i
condemn the proud boys
i don't know much about the proud boys
almost nothing but i condemn that
but he should condemn also antifa
antifa is a horrible group of people
they kill people
they what they do to people and they're
causing insurrection they're causing
riots he doesn't want to do that but the
press doesn't go after him and that's a
really bad group of people
but i condemn them and if i can if i say
it a hundred
if i say it a hundred times it won't be
enough because it's fake news
mr president i played earlier joe biden
is out there all day today saying you've
never condemned
white nationalists you just did you've
never condemned segregation as you just
did
you've never condemned the kkk you have
and you've never condemned david duke
you you are condemning all of them
tonight
on record tonight sir is that correct
yes but i've condemned them in the past
for years i've condemned people and
i think almost everything that you
mentioned what
hasn't been condemned is his crime bill
where he talks about super predators
that was the worst thing that ever
happened to the black community
for the young men and women of the black
community that was
sleepy joe biden mark levin went through
and and we've done it on this program
too an exhaustive examination of joe
biden's history on racial issues
he did refer to robert byrd the former
klansman
as my friend and mentor that's the man
that filibustered the civil rights act
that's the man against the voting rights
act and robert byrd was the man that joe
biden partnered with
to stop bussing and integration of
schools because
i'll use the words of joe he didn't want
his kids going to schools that were a
racial jungle
are you calling on joe biden to
apologize
to anybody tonight are you condemning
him for his remarks
because what he did was terrible and he
has to do it